les meneurs politique bonjour à tous et
bienvenue dans l'hebdo politique votre
rendez vous politique du dimanche soir
sur tv et 78 et radio sensations
dimanche 23 mai épisode 199 notre invité
ce soir et ghislaine ce n'est les
politiques
ghislaine ce n'est bon jour vous êtes
conseillère régionale depuis 2010 et
tête de liste dans le département des
yvelines de la liste menée par julien
bayou secrétaire nationale d'europe
écologie les verts pour les élections
régionales en ile-de-france vous êtes
aussi l'ancien maire de la ville des
vêtements 800 habitants si je ne me
trompe pas à peu près ghislaine se
disent que c'est là-bas d'ailleurs que
vous avez profité du début du
déconfinement qui a débuté mercredi et
puis est ce que d'ailleurs vous avez eu
le temps d'en profiter un peu puisque
vous êtes en campagne et et que le temps
doit doit vous manqué quelques fois et
pas du tout j'ai pas pu en profiter
la nouvelle équipe avaient avait
justement organisé une petite rencontre
sur sur la place et en fait non j'ai pas
pu être j'ai pas pu être présente mais
la vente à ce que vous avez pour
ambition tout de même valeur en terrasse
bientôt d'aller au musée où aller nous
n'avons pas de terrain ça vous savez oui
non alors voilà oui oui j'espère bien
j'espère bien pouvoir y arriver je n'ai
pas fait encore j'ai pas encore été sur
sur une terrasse mais c'est pas
forcément justement une habitude par
ailleurs que nous avons quand on habite
dans un village de rural en fait nous
coller nous on aime bien c'est pouvoir
se retrouver sur la place sur la place
du village et on espère que ça va
pouvoir bientôt reprendre vous avez dû
voir tout de même si ces images un peu
partout en france et notamment région
ile de france de jeunes qui se sont
rassemblés je parle de jeunes mais aussi
de moins jeunes pour profiter du
déconfinement et dépasser un peu parfois
les limites les règles sanitaires et
puis l'horaire est ce que vous comprenez
cette envie de
la jeunesse de vouloir se rassembler
quitte à être un peu dans l'illégalité
si je puis me permettre
ou alors vous appeler à la prudence tout
de même dans ces premiers temps pour pas
que l'on ait à nouveau un pic épidémique
non mais je pense que ça le premier soir
évidemment c'était c'était évident enfin
il y avait vraiment aidé à réaliser une
réelle envie et puis on a fait les
caisses allaient ministre nouri
terrasses de café salé disant que ce
genre depuis dix ans que ça y est on
allait sortir du déconfinement donc
c'est normal que le premier soir par
contre effectivement enfin il faut il ya
des règles qu'il faut encore respectée à
une prudence qu'il faut qu'il faut
absolument respecter on n'est pas encore
sortis de cette crise sanitaire et donc
et donc voilà il ya eu ses premiers
soirs mais maintenant je pense que tout
le monde doit doit fallait les cafés
premier à inventer une aire s'organiser
pour pouvoir les fermer on a beaucoup
parlé d'eux des milieux très urbanisé où
on a vu ces foules se rassemblent et
qu'en est il justement dans les villages
comment ça a été accueillie est ce que
là aussi il un vrai ouf de soulagement
ou comme vous semblez le dire au début
de l'émission c'est quand même très
différent quand on vit dans ces villages
moi je crois que c'est
c'est très différent en fait on a on n'a
pas cette distance qui fait
qu'effectivement il n'ya pas il n'y a
pas foule dans les rues donc on a
toujours eu cette volonté enfin moi je
le vois dans ma rue de pouvoir continuer
en fait à garder un contact avec avec
ses voisins donc donc effectivement on
n'a pas sorti les tables pour être tous
ensemble au milieu de la rue mais mais
c'est une tradition que nous avons chez
nous nous aimons bien parfois le soir se
retrouver et puis partager un moment de
convivialité on semble tout le monde en
a envie et donc et donc voilà ça va ça
va pouvoir se remettre en place mais par
contre effectivement il faut et les
équipes municipales doivent le faire
montrer l'exemple et faire en sorte que
lorsqu'il ya une heure à respecter il
faut l'être humain besoins ses 21 ans et
que ce sera 23h ce déconfinement rime
avec aussi l'accélération de la campagne
pour les élections départementales et
régionales qui se tiendront le 20 et 27
juin prochains jeux aura appel
est ce que c'est c'est difficile de
faire campagne dans ces conditions ou
alors avec ce déconfinement tout de même
on arrive à retrouver des habitudes de
rencontrer du monde de pouvoir faire des
réunions publiques sachant que vous êtes
élu depuis 2010 vous avez connu d'autres
campagnes comme celle de 2015
non mais 7,7 cette campagne difficile
cette campagne est difficile parce
qu'effectivement on n'a pas la même
capacité à pouvoir se réunir et
notamment simplement avec les militants
nous avons fait une lancement de la
liste sur internet
normalement on en était au même au
palais des congrès de versailles
on aurait eu tous nos militants c'est
cette regroupement de sept partis
politiques donc on aurait pu avoir
vraiment voilà des drapeaux dans dans la
salle
et là il a fallu qu'on fasse sur
internet les centièmes c'est difficile
de mobiliser les gens les militants
c'est plus compliqué d'autant plus que
effectivement avant on avait on avait la
possibilité de se retrouver dans un
hôtel de campagne
et puis et puis être là je me sens en
confiance donc là il faut qu'on intègre
ça il a fallu qu'on l'intérieur ils ont
développé bien évidemment l'outil que ce
soit 12 août ims mais être bien d'autres
montrent même mêmes voilà pour être
tension mais c'est vrai que du coup la
réactivité et puis le contacter et moi
est moins présent et moi je m'interroge
encore par exemple sur le porte à porte
le porte-à-porte dans dans les secteurs
pavillonnaires ou on reste à la porte du
jardin et on aurait dit à l'extérieur
pourquoi pas mais le porte-à-porte à
l'intérieur dans dans les immeubles moi
moi je m'interroge encore aujourd'hui
devant vous ne savez pas si vous allez
en faire d'ici le 20 juin à absolument
en fait il faut qu'on entame je pense
qu'on va faire des choix parce que parce
que
le virus est toujours à ce que est ce
que vous pensez que malheureusement et
puissants sans que ce soit conscientiser
ce que vous pensez que tout de même le
contexte est cette drôle de campagne
profite au candidat sortant dans chacune
des régions et donc en ile-de-france à
valérie pécresse qui elle peut être un
moindre besoin de faire campagne on
connaît plus sa politique
m elle est aussi plus médiatisé oui oui
moi tout à fait je pense à mes ou mais
au même titre que pour que pour des
municipales il ya forcément une prime
enfin il ya déjà de toutes façons de
base une prime aux sortants et là dans
ce contexte particulier effectivement
c'est beaucoup plus facile pour pour
elle d'autant plus qu'elle qu'à luz et
abusant de de sa position de présidente
de région face est facile de faire des
promesses en disant voilà nous avons
aujourd'hui un faux seins fondettes
d'urgence résilience pour les
commerçants et bien si je suis élu et
bien j'efface ray lane est pour elle
cesser c'est beaucoup plus facile de
pouvoir nous apporter ce type de
promesses électorales donc
donc oui ça va être c'est compliqué mais
d'un autre côté on est aussi dans un
contexte politique difficile il ya quand
même beaucoup de discrédit les ans au
moment des grandes promesses ça c'est
pas du fait du coup vite ça fait
beaucoup visiblement je crois que le
pacs et l'air aussi à créer un état
d'esprit
oui pourquoi pas la tête à penser aux
régionales et aux départementales quand
on a envie d'aller en terrasse ou voir
ses amis ou sa famille absolument
assassin alors on l'a bien vu d'ailleurs
beaucoup de personnes ne sont pas encore
tout à fait conscient qu'il va y avoir
des élections à qui c'est dans un mois
tout pile absolument c'est dans un mois
et est et dans les médias par exemple on
n'a pas encore beaucoup parler ça
commence c'est une aventure tellement vu
comment plaisir que j'ai c'est vous pour
parler de de cette campagne on la voit
tout même viré vers le sujet sécuritaire
alors c'est pas nécessairement une
une prérogative de la région mais tout
de même ça se s'entrechoquent avec
l'actualité ghislaine sonné et puis vous
avez dû voir ces images de la colère des
policiers qui ont manifesté un peu
partout en france suite aux attaques
subies par plusieurs de leurs collègues
notamment une fonctionnaire de police le
23 avril à rambouillet les policiers qui
ont manifesté devant l'assemblée
nationale à paris cette semaine c'était
mercredi avec un slogan qui a fait
beaucoup parler de lui le problème de la
police c'est la justice
est-ce que vous en tant que responsable
politique élu depuis 2010 à la région de
fond de vous entendez cette colère est
ce que vous partez vous partager aussi
cette position de de manifester avec les
policiers qui a été celle de nombreux
hommes politiques dont yannick jadot qui
totalise des eurodéputés verts au
parlement européen qui est quelqu'un
d'important dans votre parti est ce que
vous auriez manifestez-vous peut-être
vous l'avez fait aussi non moi je ne les
je ne les ai pas fait et je suis par
contre assez contente que yannick jadot
et été et était présent mais il a été
présent pour rendre hommage
en fait il a il a été des présents pour
soutenir non à l'ours de police alors il
n'empêche que dans les images on voit
ces slogans et on voit des hommes
politiques donc on est obligé aussi de
faire le rapprochement
bien sûr non mais je crois que en fait
il y avait il y avait vraiment l'eau
pour cette manifestation un vrai
télescopage c'est à dire qu' il y avait
ce qui est alliée pour vraiment dire
mais oui mais oui au gourbi donnons les
moyens à nos forces de police
c'est enfin la sécurité des biens et des
personnes c'est un des premiers droit
citoyen et donc où écologistes nous
pensons qu effectivement il faut
aujourd'hui un vrai pouvoir régalien en
fait une vraie capacité à donner les
moyens aux forces aux forces de
de sûreté aux forces de sécurité et on a
aujourd'hui effectivement vrai sujet
lorsque c'est pas un sujet tabou
d'ailleurs pour l'homme parce que c'est
souvent ça c'est ce qu'on entend dans
les débats que la gauche problème avec
la sécurité un peu trop laxistes vous
n'êtes pas d'accord avec cela
notamment les écologistes qui sont un
peu dépeint parfois comme des
excusez-moi l'expression mais des
bisounours alors des bisounours où je
vais l'aider ou alors des libertaires
qui refusent le moindre respect des
règles en fait on a on a vraiment faim
moi en tout cas je suis et je pense que
notre parti malgré les attaques que l'on
peut avoir nous sommes vraiment très
républicain nous sommes très attachés
aux valeurs républicaines et nous savons
que il y à un certain nombre de de falla
publics s'engagent à pouvoir assurer la
sécurité des citoyens et donc et donc
nous pensons réellement que c'est un
droit enfin une compétence régalienne
auquel il faut absolument apporter
apporter les moyens tant dans la
rénovation des commissariats de police
que dans que dans le recrutement
mais nous sommes aussi très attaché à la
séparation des pouvoirs et la question
pendant sa pseudo
et je pense réellement que c'est un des
piliers aussi une des valeurs fortes de
notre république
nous devons assumer cette séparation a
des pouvoirs qu'elle sait que des hommes
politiques ont pu se faire avoir
mercredi dernier en manifestant d'une
bonne intention et puis avec ce je ne
sais pas si c'est se faire avoir enfin
je veux dire je pense que humainement
chacun avait le choix et notre parti
hong hao respecte sa ses désirs chacun
un peu ce que ça m'a choqué j'ai appelé
à manifester sous cet angle c'est s
étaient des personnalités des
personnalités politiques qui ont fait le
choix soit de dire bah pour moi rendre
hommage enfin aux victimes et montrer
notre soutien c'est plus important que
finalement bas les revendications
ouh là là là là là je cherche mon beau
mais la volonté par exemple de la droite
ou de l'extrême droite de vouloir
récupérer en fait cette cette
manifestation à leurs profils ont
terminé sur cette sécurité on peut on
peut sur le thème sécurité on peut tout
de même en parler en lien avec les
élections régionales puisque la région
ile-de-france et en charge des
transports on sait qu'il ya des
problèmes parfois de sécurité dans les
transports en commun notamment ceux qui
qui se déverse dans la dans la région
ile de france au bout des lignes qui
sont peut-être moins sécurisé est ce que
c'est un axe de campagne pour votre lit
pour votre liste l'écologie évidemment
lorsque l'ours avait des propositions
notes suaves absolument absolument nous
par exemple dans la halle dans les
transports ou proposons et nous
souhaitons mettre en place à ce que ce
soit la région qui est systématiquement
porter plainte lorsque il y à des
personnes victimes de harcèlement on
sait aujourd'hui que on a on a si une
forte réactivité
en fait on a la possibilité de pouvoir
résoudre résoudre ccc à faire en fait
c'est à dire que les personnes qui vont
porter plainte je crois le chiffre est à
80% en fait on peut en fait ce que je
peux donc dès que quelqu'un soit victime
de harcèlement de afin de tout ce que
l'on peut subir quand quand on est dans
l'est dans les transports en commun et
bien voilà on mettra à disposition un
numéro où ce sera la région qui élira
systématiquement porté porté plainte ce
qui permettra de pouvoir saisir les
bandes vidéo et donc de pouvoir voilà
faire en sorte en toute impunité on ne
puisse pas le laisser continuer à faire
ça dans les transports en compte
ghislaine ce nom on découvre
progressivement le programme de chacune
des listes on a on a pu en découvrir
quelques-unes sur votre site internet de
campagne sur sur les transports en
commun évidemment c'est le nerf de la
guerre
en ile de france on le sait entre les
les trains qui ne sont pas
nécessairement à l'heure en bon état les
embouteillages la pollution le manque de
services publics aussi dans les zones
rurales
vous vous posez vous proposer à ce
propos une solution de transport à moins
de 15 minutes de chaque de chaque
logement dans toute la région
est ce que c'est possible concrètement
ça même dans les zones les plus rurales
est ce que c'est pas un coût trop
important d'offrir des services publics
partout
si on comprend l'intention on la partage
tous mais il y aussi une réalité
financière aujourd'hui mais il y en a et
et financière c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui nous ne faisons pas le
choix de la gratuité des résultats
absolument parce que nous pensons
effectivement qu'il ya encore du de
l'investissement à faire dans l'offre
dans l'offre de services le transport
public c'est pour nous un vrai levier
pour pouvoir faire en sorte de pot de
répondre en fait à la question d'urgence
du risque climatique parce qu'on sait
que l'usagé individuel de la voiture et
est un voile à de gros pourvoyeurs et de
co2 et de pollution et donc nous pensons
qu effectivement le transport public est
une bonne solution
à 15 minutes de chez soi ça veut pas
dire qu'on fera venir le métro ou le rer
à 15 minutes d'être plutôt un bus mais
ce sera bien évidemment par exemple le
transport à la demande le transport à la
demande
sur ce dernier mandat à manger était
président de la commission offre de
transport sûr sur le mandat précédent à
la région j'ai beaucoup travaillé sur le
développement de l'offre bus sur
l'adéquation d'ailleurs entre le
transport ferré structurants et se
transporte deux derniers kilomètres
offre aux bus qui ne se concrétisent pas
forcément par la mise en place d'une
énorme bus qui arriverait dans le
village ruraux mais en tout cas des
navettes qui permettrait à 2 de pouvoir
offrir réellement la possibilité pour le
jeune d'aller à son à son club sportif
ou où la personne un peu plus âgés
d'aller à aller faire ses courses y en
de marché ou rendez vous chez le médecin
c'est aux bobines ans à volterra titre
et m'en allais charia dans la région
parce que ça va voir son village mais le
nombre de villages qui lie en
ile-de-france et de coin mine de rien on
ne le sait pas assez souvent mais c'est
une région de même assez rural mais la
leçon absolue c'est possible
financièrement de soutenir ce genre de
projets partout c'est en l'espèce de
sauvian
c'est absolument possible de pouvoir
financer ça et puis il n'ya pas que ça
il faut aussi par exemple pour les
jeunes qui demeurent va à son à son
sport à pratiquer son sport
l'idéal c'est qu'ils puissent y avoir
des infrastructures notamment cyclables
pour qu'ils puissent y aller en vélo
c'est à dire que lorsque le déplacement
fait moins de trois kilomètres en fait
ont jusque là
les personnes peuvent aussi utiliser
soit la marche à pied soit le vélo donc
donc bien évidemment c'est absolument
absolument faisable nous on nous pensons
que même si c'est pas des navettes des
bus on peut utiliser en fait c'est un
hubert public un univers public nous
avons effectivement des taxis par
exemple qui pourront aller prendre
prendre les personnes c'est absolument
pour les transporteurs vous parliez du
vélo vous proposer un d'offrir un vélo à
chaque nouveau lycéens de la région
c'est ce que ça va remplacer les pc de
valérie pécresse qui elle offre un pc à
chaque entrée ou au lycée alors
aujourd'hui en fait en fait le pc tel
qu'il y ait un peu l'eau contenant parce
que nous justement on est plutôt sur sur
l'avenir c'est à dire que on considère
effectivement que la question de
l'autonomie du jeune elle a la capacité
à pouvoir se déplacer plutôt que d'aller
le push et parce que c'est vraiment une
réalité nous dans le milieu rural à nos
jeunes font quoi à partir de 18 ans
c'est surtout s'ils ont des parents qui
refusent qu'ils aient droit d'auteur on
essaiera de nouveau passer leur permis
ils vont passer leur permis et donc on
continue en fait à développer la
question de l' usage individuel de la
voiture et nous pensons qu'il faut
donner la possibilité aux plus jeunes de
pouvoir se déplacer ce qui permettrait
aussi de sécuriser la question de la
voirie de pouvoir faire ralentir de
voitures plus on aura de vélo et plus
les voitures en grande couronne
commenceront à ralentir notamment sur
sur des départementales particulièrement
les départementales qui qui traverse le
village
ghislaine sonné parlons aussi de
l'économie puisque depuis la réforme de
la loi notre désormais les régions ont
quand même un pouvoir économique qui
s'est largement développée notamment la
formation professionnelle celle des
étudiants des plus jeunes d alternance
est demandeur d'emploi on sait que ça va
être un sujet qui va être encore plus
dans l'actualité
du fait de cette sortie de crise et des
aides publiques qui vont pouvoir
s'arrêter probablement peut-être que
beaucoup de gens vont perdre leur emploi
le jour où toutes ces aides publiques
vont s'arrêter qu'est-ce que sur ce
sujet là le soutien notamment aux plus
fragiles économiquement vous proposer
avec votre liste sur la formation sur la
formation professionnelle or
malheureusement la région a perdu
la capacité de pouvoir gérer les
thématiques sur sur sur la formation
avec la réforme qu'il ya eu mais par
contre nous pensons qu effectivement il
ya une vraie demande et une capacité de
pouvoir travailler sur la reconversion
et sur l'accompagnement des plus jeunes
c'est à dire ce qui arrive aujourd'hui
et notamment avec la déscolarisation qui
qui qui qui se fait du fait de cette
crise sanitaire c'est de pouvoir
accompagner vers des métiers verts vers
des métiers qui qui puisse réellement
enfin ouvrir à l'emploi donc on a
commencé à les faire sa part à part le
soutien par exemple le financement de
certaines structures de certaines
entreprises plutôt que d'autres de
centre de formation plutôt que d'autres
absolument en fait c'est à dire qu'il
faut qu'on arrive à aa a modifié et en
faire en sorte et d'accompagner en tout
cas les entreprises les organismes vers
des verts de l'emploi de l'emploi
durable vers de l'emploi utile et qu'ils
soient en conformité
là encore avec les accords les accords
de paris on a on a aujourd'hui vraiment
énormément moyens
vous l'avez vous l'avez dit aujourd'hui
la région apporte de l'argent à des
entreprises à des très grandes
entreprises sans aucune réalisation
nous pensons aujourd'hui qu'il faut
crise et il faut quitter risée alors
crise et ça ne veut pas dire retirer les
subventions mais au contraire il faut
inciter les entreprises à aller recruter
sur des métiers qui qui sont qui sont
aujourd'hui en adéquation toujours avec
les accords de paris parce que nous
réellement la vision que l'on porte un
pour la région c'est pas une région
qu'ils soient qu'ils deviennent guichet
comme comme elle l'est devenue
aujourd'hui c'est à dire elle distribue
les subventions à tout va pour pour pour
et bien porté avec ses petits bras de
toutes ses forces
oui en ces temps de crise souligne ses
services entreprise trans est en crise
absolument
les aides d'urgence si on les a toujours
voté elles sont elles sont nécessaires
mais il faut aussi c'est le rôle de la
région il faut pouvoir regarder vers
vers le futur faut pouvoir planifier
c'est-à-dire aider mais ne pas aider
tout le monde et aider ceux qui ont une
démarche plutôt environnementale et
sociale bien sûr bien sûr on le voit
aujourd'hui on a voté la semaine
dernière en commission permanente 1
million pour renault flins moi je suis
du nord des yvelines terrible culture en
sais c'est que c'est une industrie
structurants à la construction
automobile ça fait vraiment partie de
l'adn de mon territoire
sauf que l'on sait aujourd'hui que
renault devait à choisy le roi à fermer
les usines c'est encore 2600 emplois qui
vont être supprimés
et ils ont bénéficié de 5 milliards du
de la part de l'état que d'ailleurs
valérie pécresse comme comme capcom nous
aurons un petit peu émus du fait qu'il
n'y avait pas eu de demande formelle de
l'état à ne pas licencier et à ne pas
délocaliser que vous vous auriez pas
voté le soutien 1 millions d'euros vous
l'auriez pas proposer un tel crime
c'est-à-dire sans contrepartie pas sans
contrepartie nous devions absolument
s'assurer que l'emploi reste bien en
ile-de-france et en l'occurrence ici
dans les immeubles je voudrais aborder
ghislaine et ce n'est un autre point de
votre prochain probablement le dernier
de cette émission une idée assez
originale où vous voulez lancer une
sécurité sociale de l'alimentation en
distribuant chaque mois si j'ai bien
compris un chèque de 150 euros à tous
les foyers franciliens comme ces ils
pourront ensuite faire des achats alors
pas dans tous les circuits mais dans
circuit bien pour l'alimentation bien
bien bien précis c'est une
expérimentation où là aussi les options
on se dit ils situent probablement une
bonne idée mais le coût 150 euros par
famille ça peut aussi interroger
certains des auditeurs et
téléspectateurs qui nous regardent
alors que la région pourra pas porter
vraiment cette idée de sécurité sociale
de l'alimentation seul ça c'est clair ce
que l'on veut c'est au moins faire une
expérimentation faire auprès de familles
les plus défavorisées d'abord où ce sera
tout d'abord il faut il faut vraiment
d'abord dans l'idée c'est vraiment
généralisée ça est ce qui permettrait de
pouvoir développer les circuits courts
les circuits de proximité redonner du
souffle à l'agriculture locale
en fait là encore comme à chaque fois
nous avons plutôt une une vision très
très écosystème très très très
systémique en fêtes de la deûle à dd des
politiques publiques à mettre en oeuvre
et donc l'idée il
si est de faire en sorte de pouvoir
offrir aux familles la capacité de mieux
s'alimenter
ce qui est en plus c'est très vertueux
sur les questions les questions de la
course entre dans un premier temps ce
sera dédié aux familles les plus
fragiles c'est c'est en tout cas une
expérimentation absolument tout à fait
mais c'est vraiment par contre un
objectif sur le long terme que l'on veut
que l'on porte alors pour appliquer
toutes ses idées il faut remporter les
élections régionales ça part et ça
paraît évident le premier tour se
tiendra le 20 juin prochain
selon tous les sondages que vous allez
me dire que vous ne regardez pas vous
considérez pas tout de même valu effet
créé c est très bien placée à plus 30 %
des voix vous votre liste à gauche entre
10 et 15% est ce que vous pensez pouvoir
combler le retard et remporter cette
élection régionale avec votre liste
absolument enfin nous regardons on
comprend quand on s'investit ville en
effet choc aujourd'hui les regards
d'eaux regardons les chiffres dans les
mornes et les mandats précédents en fait
on est toujours la gauche est toujours
partie séparée d'accord et je suis
encore 2010 et c'est encore le cas mais
c'est normal puisque moi liste nous
sommes nous sommes sur du scrutin de
liste nous portons des projets d'accord
donc c'est tout à fait normal et nous
avons en 2010 nous étions plusieurs
listes de gauche et nous avons remporté
la région en 2015 2014-2015 c'était 2015
nous étions plusieurs et nous avons
perdu a très peu donc on peut te fait le
pari aujourd'hui de deux listes
différentes au premier tour le
rassemblement son couteau et vous
gagnerez comme ça absolue mais du coup
ce sera pas les idées qui vont s'imposer
ça sera aussi les idées d'audrey pulvar
et de clémentine autain et et nous
travaillerons ensemble nous
travaillerons ensemble et c'est pour ça
que nous voulons nous écologistes vais
pouvoir prendre la main parce que parce
que nous voulons aller jusqu'au bout au
fait des idées que nous que nous portons
que nous partageons par ailleurs quand
même oui bout sorte heureusement mais
pas la gratuité des transports par
exemple ce que ça veut dire que si
demain il y à alliance entre vos listes
cette proposition sera retenue eh bien
nous pensons que nous sommes favorables
avec par exemple
le front de gauche sur la tarification
sociale c'est à dire effectivement
apporté la gratuité à certaines
catégories de personnes notamment les
plus jeunes vous arriveront toujours à
trouver effectivement et à faire
consensus
un mot pour terminer l'abstention c'est
aussi le risque majeur de cette élection
elle était de 54% au premier tour en
2015 on peut penser malheureusement
qu'elle sera encore plus importante en
que dites-vous très rapidement 30
secondes à ceux qui nous regardent nous
écoute juste mentionné pour pour les
appeler à voter pour vous évidemment
mais pour toutes les listes aussi
globale en fait il faut enfin on peut
pas on peut pas critiquer on peut pas
toujours dire que rien ne va et ne pas
finalement s'engager pour un projet moi
je crois qu'on peut pas continuer tout
mon seuil à une prise de conscience on
ne peut pas continuer comme ça il faut
maintenant faire en sorte que nous
mettions vraiment en place dans les
actions ce que tout le monde dit
et notamment sur les questions
écologiques donc donc si vous êtes
attaché au futur si vous êtes attaché à
l'avenir de vos enfants si vous voulez
vivre dans des conditions beaucoup plus
saine avec avec un meilleur bien-être
une meilleure qualité de l'eau et
l'iphone au lit bien évidemment quelques
légers évidemment qui se reposer a eu
dix autres listes pour c'est absolument
régionale à surrey au 27 juin prochain
on rappelle aussi que les élections
départementales en même temps merci
beaucoup ghislaine ce n'est d'avoir
participé à cet hebdo politique sera de
sensations ctv 78 je rappelle que vous
êtes la chef de file dans les yvelines
de la liste menée pour les régionales en
île de france par julien bayou candidat
des écologistes et de générations
notamment
j'ai eu de réponse voilà c'est ça merci
beaucoup chers auditeurs et
téléspectateurs vous pouvez retrouver
cette émission replay audio et vidéo sur
les sites et applications et réseaux
sociaux de radio sensations et et veston
18 merci à tous bonne soirée sur vos
médias locaux
l'hebdo politique